okay good morning
uh welcome to Edna this is a work
session on House Bill 274 where we're
going to take a look and see what
actions we need to take over the summer
the sponsor can't be here today she has
a funeral so we're going to be um
just scoping out what is necessary here
and thanks to all the members of the
committee that showed up I'm
okay so any
do any members of the committee have
thank you representative Schmidt I'm
I just assume everybody pays attention
yes representative Barona so my comments
would be that the there needs to be
significant work on this bill
and I believe that we would need to work
with the
um
yes exactly thank you being this is my
first year on The Joint legislative
committee on administrative rules and I
see the importance that they put the
role that they play
and I think that the premise of gel car
is to
put together that represent the
legislative intent of the statute and it
is not for the interest of one party
over the other and I just want to make
sure that any type of
um bias that we put that we don't put
okay thank you
well one one thing that we would
um
that I that was brought out by the staff
during the comment period was that the
um
the proposed blocking by of a rule by a
committee rather than the Full House is
um
if that's the concern then obviously
we're not going to pass an
unconstitutional bill
um
representative blackis just um what's
the actual site for the part of the
Constitution that applies to that I just
that's a very good question we'll have
to find that out
um
uh Mr director Morrow has an answer for
Madam chair uh for those of you who
don't know me I'm the director of the
administrative rules unit within the
office of legislative Services
I've worked for a gel car for 30 years
the sections of the constitution in
question are 13 14 16 and 17. uh
in 1981 the legislature was looking at
for control better oversight of
administrative rules and it posed some
questions to the Supreme Court about how
they could do that and one of the
questions was whether they could have a
single committee whether it would be
delcar which didn't exist then or a
policy committee whether that committee
could simply deny the rule in other
words kill the rule right there and the
Supreme Court said no the entire
legislature had given agencies
rulemaking Authority and a single
committee could not take that away it
would have to be an action of the entire
legislature which they have right now
through the joint resolution process
okay
if I could
spoken like us yes
um could you uh please send the
committee uh reference or the actual
um opinion written by the Supreme Court
yes
and some of these I'm sorry I do have a
citation to that it's opinion of the
justices
121 New Hampshire 552.
and that's from 1981 but I still will
okay are we going to just weigh in here
at random or well I'd like since this
issue this issue is one that I want I
want to have resolved but we don't have
the information today to do it so if you
have you have something on this issue
great if nobody else has it anything
representative shuitt we'll then we'll
take up new ones thank you
thank you madam chair
um I'm sure we've all seen the letters
from various groupings that I contained
excuse me representative schuette I'm
sorry are you talking about the
constitutionality issue no I'm talking
about the component units in in this in
that case representative Schmidt did you
have a comment next
well I mean the the thing is I'm I look
at as I look at at the bill
um I I see in early on uh either the
statements are made that uh just repeat
standing practice long time uh structure
and so forth and so on uh I guess
there's no harm in that it's kind of
like hammering on a nail that's already
flat but
um
but item four Roman four which is early
on says the standing legislative policy
committee that originally passed the
underlying statute
should be given the opportunity to
review when he proposed rules to ensure
they do not exceed the original intent
and scope of the legislation and do not
impose excessive operational or
financial burdens
that sounds
like Common Sense except uh in my view
that is completely unworkable uh because
it is workable we have this year
required the rulemaking register be sent
to every member of the legislature and
if the committee's on policy when they
get the notice in the register that
rules are being written don't take any
action to review those rules it's not
the problem is with them and not with
the pers the procedures I think that
observation is completely germane the
the point I'm raising is uh that the
legislature is basically only working
from January
until June in regular uh oversight
mode if you will
and the the rules are written on an
ongoing and reviewed and revised and so
forth on an ongoing basis 12 months a
year the gel car meets every month at
least once and twice if necessary under
our workload
and so yeah a rule that's that comes out
for review uh in the off months uh the
the policy committee is not in session
at that particular Point
um and I think that it's
um uh now you're asking the policy
committee uh in what in whatever
form it is available at that particular
time to weigh in on something that the
whole committee may have had a part of
in the January to June period but
they're not there in let's say in August
and therefore you're having a partial
committee or no committee at all to
review it and the the
rule that governs the gel car is that
they have a schedule a rule has to be
taken up at the time that it comes
before the jail car
and if it doesn't the gel car uh is is
not able to to review it
and then the rule goes into effect
excuse me representative Schmidt yes
there it there are difficulties but if
these if the policy committee
okay
we all will be getting our emails and
reading them over the summer you're
talking about a two-month shutdown I
would expect that the committee chairs
of other policy committees will also be
doing that and if they don't if they
consider the rules to be so unimportant
that they can't call a meeting of their
committee
in in they can they can ask for
permission to meet they can do something
uh
have a caucus or whatever
and if they have a rule that is that
important to them that they have to
approve it more or less then they can
get off their duffs and on vacation and
schedule something if they uh my belief
is that if they pass a law
and and and ask for rules to be written
and then they don't pay any attention to
what the agency's doing with the with to
implement that law they can't consider
it that important
yeah I I don't fundamentally disagree
with that but the thing is that the
current situation
um you know we have
the administrative rules unit which is
intensely involved in the process of
producing the rules in conjunction with
the agency which has the expertise on
the subject matter and which comes
forward with a proposal and there is
kind of a give and take back and forth
between between them their rules writers
and the administrative rules unit uh
with you know as I say a give and take
where my understanding is that the
ministry of rules unit says well you
know this is going to have a problem
with a gel car for X Y and Z
however the
the rule making register comes out
several months in advance of the gel car
meeting and the final review of the
staff with the preliminary Rule and
there is a public hearing after that
time that's the time right after the
register comes out for any member of the
legislature who cares about the subject
to read the rule and comment
goodness wouldn't you agree with that
I'd absolutely agree that that is their
opportunity well that's that's what
we've given them the chance we've we're
sending them in the register if they are
choosing to ignore it they're they're
saying that it's not worth their bother
I think that's a fair interpretation but
I think it's also a very effectively a
very haphazard
situation I'm not saying that it
couldn't work and you couldn't get a
useful input from uh from a member of
the policy committee correct but on the
other hand the actions of the policy
committee are not set by law but by the
house rules
okay and it's up to the
to the committee chairs and the speaker
to determine what the committee is is
obligated to do the speaker has told me
he intends to have set up a standing
subcommittee in every policy committee
that will review rules and that is
entirely within his scope
you know that the house rules say you
you look at the you look at agency rules
when you're passing the laws to create
them
all right and I think that is the
appropriate place to bring that into
effect rather than in statute because we
don't have to follow statute if we don't
want to for the most part
well I'm I I don't disagree with the
with the fundamental premise but I see
representative
I'll defer to him for the moment
representative I would say um you know
even if uh representative Schmidt's
correct and in most cases the committee
won't take advantage the opportunity or
exercise the responsibility to review
the rules
having a process set up where they can
and maybe be reminded they can I think
would be useful even if it's only used
in extraordinary circumstances where
there's something the committee really
I I agree that the
we can't force the legislative
committees to take action
I'm I'm
if you know a way to do that I'd love to
but we don't have that that Authority we
don't have that power
so the most we can do is to make sure
they know about this stuff
and force feeding them of the rule
making register every week
all right and if people look at it they
can identify either that their policy
areas or things they know about from
their previous lives
which are pro which are probably at
least as useful because
um
you've got to know the context of the
rule in order to see what's going on
with it
well I we can't force them to work and I
agree we should take it out of here it
doesn't belong in here
okay I again I I think it you you get
into a situation I mean one of one of
the things that some of you know some of
you don't know is representative McGuire
has been on the gel car for what 10 or
12 14 years I think and I've been on for
like 18 years so we know that the rules
don't look like statutes
they just don't
um and that that's exactly why the
administrative rules unit has highly
trained and experienced lawyers to
review the rules as they are written and
whether they properly implement the
statutes or
overreach the statutes and so forth
that's their function and that's exactly
their expertise now you're asking
legislators who by and large have no
experience with the rules to look at
them and try and interpret them and so
forth I think that's a little bit like
having somebody who's looking at their
first football game comment on the
coach's strategy representative Schmidt
the thing is that the rules apply to our
citizens if the legislators can't read
them and understand them nobody else can
either
don't wouldn't you agree that the point
of the rules is have something that the
yes but but they they are the the people
who are the practitioners of a
particular trade or occupation
they know and and and
not an insignificant number of cases
they are involved in the rule writing
process because as the rules are written
they see what that's going to do to them
um and they and they do weigh in yeah
and say this is not this is the way to
get the legislators to weigh in the same
way that the the affected population
does because
we may very well be in that affected
population there's no reason we can't be
again I think that you're you're asking
for uh legislators to weigh in
and if they don't you're you've already
comment on the fact that they don't care
enough or whatever or they don't see a
problem
they'll be silent and that that's a
tacit approval but I do think it creates
the haphazard situation where uh the
legislators are
um likely to be as not as knowledgeable
as the stakeholders and the rural
writers we have a haphazard situation
now where the stakeholders may or may
not notice that the rules are being
some of them get very involved some of
them get surprised and you've you've
been at enough jail car meetings where
someone affected by the rule comes in
and I'm sure that we're not going to
have a
we're never going to be able to develop
a procedure where that doesn't happen
sometimes
anyone else yes
if the intent of legislation is to get
the legislation to get the legislators
involved I think there's other ways of
doing that right without writing law
yeah well like I said the speaker
intends to set up subcommittees on the
policy committees
to do that which is
probably a much more effective approach
than just telling people the rules are
coming out but
that's his authority and not ours
thank you um
I can see the worth of having
committees with expertise in various
areas looking at rules I believe if I
recall correctly
an invitation was put out earlier this
session for individual legislators who
were concerned to look at rules and in
the process and as far as I heard hardly
any responded and I think that's what
you're going to find I think most
legislators who serve on other
committees are busy with their specific
responsibilities and are probably just
as happy to leave the gel car committee
deal with administrative Wellness I
believe that's what you'll find that's
what I have found is that they don't
know they don't care about the rules or
they don't bother about the rules but
that's what the sponsor is concerned
with that that
there isn't it's oversight and I
you know sometimes I agree with that it
needs to be done and sometimes I think
it's unnecessary but I I believe that
all legislators should look at the rules
and determine if there's an issue
particularly if they've just spent
a whole session writing a new law they
ought to be looking at how it's being
implemented
but I can't force them to to do it
that's why we've come in further uh you
know you and I know from sitting at gel
car meetings uh and I've I think I've I
missed a couple of hours of one gel car
meeting one time about 15 years ago but
otherwise I'm there at nine o'clock and
I'm there until we're done
um and and the one thing that I can
comment with absolute certainty based on
my nearly capitalist attendance is that
legislators do not attend the jail care
meetings when the specific rule is
coming up sometimes for the first time
sometimes rules of course they since
they only have a 10-year period of
validity
um the rules get re-adopted all the time
in some permanent rules have gotten
adopted initially and never get looked
at again unless unless the stature goes
out of goes out of the validity itself
whereas repealed but the bottom line is
sometimes these rules are brand new
because it's a new statute
and it's an opportunity for the
legislators to come in and comment at
the very moment when the public is there
it's their golden opportunity
we rarely see any member of the
legislature I agree with you that that's
correct that's true I do think that it's
much more effective for the legislators
in question
to comment to the rules and
be at the public hearing on the
preliminary rules because that's while
the agency is still obliged to hear the
public
and consider their comments in in
adjusting the rules if the rules have
been so
if they've done their Duty can commented
on the rules at that point they may be
perfectly happy with the final proposal
I don't disagree with that either I
wonder I remember being at a board
meeting one time about a rule that was
upcoming and so forth
um that's uh one of the few times that
I've been there and I'm on the jail car
so I wonder to the administrator of the
rules unit who is participating in this
how often they see legislators present
at those at that initial public hearing
and I would ask them to believe that the
gel car staff is at the initial public
hearing are you no they're not there
yeah well
and I know that at least I have been
trying to train various groups of
legislators how to read the rulemaking
register and I know at least one person
who read it and decided to comment on on
one set of rules that he that he knew
about from his own personal life
but you know that's one out of 400.
thank you madam chairman RSA 541a right
now does allow for my office to attend
agencies public hearings we haven't done
that for some time because of the
workload but with the staff now I would
like to see us do some of that well
particularly where we after looking at
to register we feel that it's an issue
that may be complicated or contentious
excellent I would hope you would use
your
that Authority and your staff time
wisely I mean
you can't do everything all right anyone
else representative yeah I I was
prepared for another argument looking
particularly at the elements of the bill
itself and I admit that I did not look
at it closely earlier in the session
because it was stated pretty early on
that it was going to be retained but
seeing the letters that we received
recently
pertaining particularly to the repeal of
exemptions from writing rules I do have
concerns about these component units uh
being included now in administrative
rules I assume that's what the repeal
would do I think as stated in a couple
of the letters the
legislative intent was clear when these
segments
and I I hesitate to even say of state
government because they technically are
not state agencies for my understanding
were Exempted from rules because they
are not under the auspices of any of the
executive branch or that's not who they
report to and I I think that they should
probably not be
expected to do administrative rules and
I'm further going on in those sections
I'm curious about why those specific
sections from Health and Human Services
are also now now going I assume when
they were first put in they were
Exempted and that's Pages 15 and 16.
Romans 19 20 and 21 I'm curious why they
were Exempted and why they would now be
expected to do rules I am afraid I don't
have an answer for that my my having
and I I honestly have to say that most
of them and I haven't examined a lot of
the rest of the bill but were those
concerns were rained raised I'm
wondering if there are other sections
that are questionable well yeah yeah I
mean the
adoption of the state fire code and the
and the State Building Code
I don't believe they go through 541 they
they don't they should need to go
through 541a and some of the technical
ones from the Department of
Transportation
um
State speed zones and excavation permits
on the on the highway I mean that's
don't need to go through rules for that
so anyway yes I I don't expect
I will say to everybody that this bill
is not going to go forward as is written
I expect we're going to take a lot of
these elements out of it
I want to know which other ones are our
issues and these exemptions are all need
to be I think would need to be looked at
anyone representative Lucas on on this
issue I looked through it and well I
didn't look at each one of them and see
what they all had to do with I did look
at at particularly the ones we got email
on
and um
I have kind of a larger question on that
we from one of the organizations I said
they you know they're not part of the
state government they
uh State doesn't pay anything they're
not part of the pension system all that
stuff
so my question is
what is their association with the state
why are they
why are they not just like any other
non-profit registered with the secretary
of state and operate independently other
than you know whatever those
requirements are and and you know if
they were doing that then obviously they
wouldn't be part of the administrative
rule process but since they are somehow
affiliated with the state I'd like to at
least understand
what that why that affiliation is there
what is it and then maybe then I could
decide whether or not having them part
of the rules process made any sense
excellent question you know why are they
in statute if they're not part of state
government
is there anyone who would be able to
answer that question
please can identify yourself and
thank you madam chair my name is Ben
Frost I'm the deputy executive director
and chief legal officer of the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority and
we are one of those entities that
submitted to you a letter expressing our
very serious concerns about the repeal
of our rulemaking exemption
New Hampshire housing was created by the
legislature in 1981 with the passage of
RSA chapter 204 C
uh and that that accomplished the
combination of two pre-existing State
entities the New Hampshire Housing
Commission and the New Hampshire housing
agency
and this follows a pattern uh employed
by many states in fact there are 42
similar organizations in other states
State Housing Finance agencies or
authorities
we were created by the legislature
to perform and our statute says
essential governmental functions
but to operate with a high degree of
autonomy from the state so that we can
act
in essence as a private Market actor
so for example we at New Hampshire
housing do single-family mortgage
lending and we occupy a space of between
five and ten percent of the state's
mortgage lending
our focus is on areas where the private
Market itself has some difficulty
operating and that is with regard to say
that the first time home buyer people
who don't have
um a lot of money to make uh you know a
20 down payment and who are you know
saddled with lots of other debt like
student debt but who are in a good
financial position and
um but for the lack of capital in the
private Market would be able to buy a
home and do because of the products that
we're able to offer
um
so
so we've talked about single family
lending we also administer a variety of
federal programs which are uniquely
tailored by federal law to be run by
state Housing Finance agencies so as a
a governmental actor but not strictly
speaking part of state government we're
not a state agency we're not and the the
component units statute which was
adopted by the legislature in 2018
clearly identifies us as
part of state government but not part of
the Executive Branch the legislative
representative so you have a follow-up
yeah thank you so
um
you know other than you mentioned
um some federal programs that you end up
being involved in I guess administering
at the state level
what else is it
about what you do that would require you
to be a creature basically of the state
or however you want to put it and rather
than just a an independent non-profit or
whatever
no that's it's a great question and it
is kind of a a legal structure that is
required for us to be eligible for a
certain funding sources from the federal
government so we have uh and and we
share this New Hampshire housing share
that shares this with the the business
Finance Authority and I'll identify a
couple of my colleagues James key
Wallace is the executive director of the
business Finance Authority he's behind
me Bonnie Payette is the executive
director of the health and education
facilities Authority also here
uh we have similar structures with the
with the business Finance Authority New
Hampshire housing shares the state's
allocation of tax exempt Municipal
bonding Authority uh and that that has
to be exercised by a governmental entity
and so we we split that Authority and
the BFA does commercial lending uh and
New Hampshire housing does housing
lending so with that capacity to do
tax-exempt bonding we are able to
finance the development of affordable
rental housing that otherwise would not
get built follow-up
my question my final question is just um
so does the New Hampshire Housing
Authority Finance Authority receive any
money
from the state other than maybe pass
through from the federal government
we do we do not receive any operating
funds from the state
so we are entirely funded through the
programs that we administer the funding
that we have received from the state is
the state's affordable housing trust
fund
uh and that is in our Statute in RSA
204c and you'll recall in this year's
House Bill 2 there was a 25 million
dollar allocation to an appropriation to
the affordable housing fund so that is a
the state's affordable housing trust
fund that we administer on behalf of the
state we are by Statute
authorized
to take I think
8.3 percent of interest income
from that but we have never done that
all of the money goes to development all
right thank you
so if I understand you correctly
your
not quite part of state government
structure is primarily to deal with the
federal government and their rules and
regulations
Computing tax-exempt financing Madam
chair that is that is true uh
but it also gives us the flexibility to
do things that
um honestly it's difficult for the state
to do so if there's
um I'll give you an example the uh arpa
funded invest NH initiative of of the
governor I and I know you're shaking
your head
um uh once that has gone through
governor and Council and Joint fiscal
committee
um then a a contract to us to administer
funds doesn't need to go back to GNC for
further approval we're able to work with
developers very flexibly to come to
terms of development that would be
appropriate for them so that that's an
area where a state agency has great
difficulty operating
but the only reason you're even
affiliated with the state rather than
being a
not-for-profit housing lender is because
the federal government requires you you
I suppose uh I will concede that point I
I think fundamentally and historically
that is the basis of our existence okay
well I'm we're quite used to seeing
Federal red tape and strings attached
all over the place this is just yet
another example
uh there
anyone else
I guess my question is the main
difficulty you have with this particular
bill is what they wanted to add where
you would have the the money if you
should fail or something should not work
out the state would have to pick up
ear debt and that's what we want to get
rid of because the state doesn't want
that responsibility
that that's a great Point great question
and we do address that in our letter and
I think each of the letters from our
agencies identifies something similar
um
as things stand
the state
clearly legally is not responsible for
our debt
and New Hampshire housing has currently
about a half a billion dollars of debt
that varies over time depending upon
which programs we're using it has been
well in excess of a billion dollars at
at some times in the past the BFA has
substantially larger debt as does as
does the health and education facilities
Authority
um and as things are structured right
now uh that debt clearly is not legally
attributable to the state
because of the wall that exists between
the state proper and our entities our as
uh creatures of statute
once that wall starts to be taken down
then it is more difficult for the state
to disavow that debt
that's what I thought okay thank you
um
regarding this debt you say you can
issue some portion of state tax exempt
debt is is your debt backed by the full
faith of the state no
okay it is not
good otherwise you're wouldn't it would
make a difference okay any other
questions
comments all right
thank you madam chair all right thank
any other concerns or issues
representative blackis yep um one sort
of minor knit on page eight
uh let me get the line here
on page 8 line 31
um it references subparagraphs to c and
e and immediately prior to that it
actually uh eliminates section e so
if we go anywhere with this that's a
minor thing that should be fixed
oh okay thank you very much and then
um
sort of a more General thing on page
seven
starting line 17 or 18.
this is about
things that are Incorporated by
reference and rules
um you know the agency has to or the
adopting Authority has to explain how
the text of the Incorporated document or
Internet content can be obtained by the
public and at what cost
and I know this isn't changed as part of
this bill but um
the idea that the state's going to
promulgate rules that apply to citizens
to the state and they're going to have
to pay to find out what those rules are
is
and then one final one which is the
various places here it talks about you
um do any retaliation if people object
or whatever
um
on rules and there was actually one bit
that was already in there but there's at
least a couple that are being added I
guess the general question is um
you know if there is an accusation of
that or someone thinks they've been
retaliated against what's the process
for them to uh seek a remedy what's I
mean putting things in where there's no
enforcement
doesn't mean anything
representative Schmidt
thank you
um so I
um I've slightly addressed this uh in
some aspect of my earlier remarks but uh
one of the proposals in this in this
bill is in Roman 3
the committee shall hold public hearings
on a proposed or previously adopted rule
on its own initiative and the change
there or the the point there is that the
current statute already says the
committee May hold
so now we're going from May to Shell
which means that the committee is now
obligated to hold meetings on
proposal previously had
I I wonder whether the administrative
rules unit can tell us about any
previous
iterations of this concept under the
existing statute which says they made to
do so my my belief would be that that
ain't happening ain't never happened
with any degree of regularity and now to
tell the policy committees that they
shall be holding
hearings on this is to ask
effectively that the Committees lift
themselves up by their own bootstraps
I I tend to agree with you that that
I've never heard of that that sort of
thing
representative I think it was tried
thank you
um in the past there have been
just a handful of instances where a gel
car and staff would look at already
adopted rules it was a very rare
occurrence to require this could be a
huge problem it would definitely be a
huge undertaking because there are
thousands of pages of rules in state in
fact Health and Human Services probably
has a few thousand by itself because of
its relationship with the federal
government and Medicare
um
and it would create create a tremendous
burden for my office and for gel car to
where the chair's permission well I
would ask would you like me to go back
over some of the issues that I had
if I have your comments right here okay
um is there any any highlights that you
think are
that are vital
um beside the constitutionality
um
well there's another constitutional
issue
right now under the current law for
example for joint resolutions there are
requirements that the legislature act on
those joint resolutions when the certain
time frame
that was put into 541a over 20 years ago
the reason being is that if gel Carr
voted to
um for our joint res to make a motion
for a joint resolution
and then just sat on it or if it was
sent to the entire legislature and the
legislature sat on it it would actually
become a pocket veto of the rule and
that would be unconstitutional
and this rule um under this uh bill that
would be allowed
um
there's many places where there's
conflicting language that would limit or
there are a lot of new terms like
substantial operational impact and
excessive burdens that aren't clarified
one major factor is that right now gel
carb May object when a basis exists and
while gel car is an oversight they don't
vote on policy but there are times they
can still extend practical
considerations to a rule there may be a
rule that has very minor issue but gel
Carr realizes that to object and delay
the rule is going to cause more severe
problems than to
if they do enter the objection I
remember an instance where Environmental
Services had to meet a federal deadline
or they were going to lose a substantial
amount of money there was a minor issue
with the rule but the committee chose
not to object because of the financial
Factor
this would require gel car to object in
all instances by changing made shell and
frankly when we review the rule for the
committee it's statutorily required for
us to raise any potential basis for
objection we know from practice that
there are things that the committee
would never object to are very unlikely
to object to but they would be required
to object to it now even if it's
editorial punctuation issue or something
technically that violates the rulemaking
manual violation of the manual violates
RSA 541a8
so that would create quite a problem Oh
I absolutely
if nothing else but this year we've
we've seen that in many many cases where
there was a conflict of fee Authority
for for licensing agencies and we knew
that a legislative
fix was in process but it was not yet
effective we would not want to object to
any of the rules because they were
essentially in line with the forward
legislative intent
unless there were other reasons too of
course
one other point that I would raise final
Point
um
by having the lead gel car or any
standing committee look at a policy I
mean gel car already looks to see not
for policy but to see whether a rule
conforms with legislative intent in
other words with the statute it's rare
that it goes beyond that there are
instances where we would look up a
legislative history to get some language
on intent but this would allow for
example for a Edna to look at a rule a
new uh say an amended rule a rule that's
been in existence for 20 years and then
that committee whether gel car or the
standing committee could say no we don't
think this conforms with the legislative
intent well my question would be how
does the legislative committee today
determine what the intent of the bill
was that came through 20 or 30 years ago
that gave the statutory authority to the
agency
thank you so it to me the the the
fundamental issue here is whether we
currently have a situation which is
essentially workable
it's it's timely uh it it uh it involves
people with expertise uh and who are
um and and who are specifically tasked
with looking at the aspect of whether uh
the two fundamental pillars of gel cars
function namely is a rule excessive does
it exceed legislative Authority
um and the second main pillar is whether
it violates legislative intent uh there
are a couple of the other two thing as
you know there's a financial aspect and
also public interest but they are
narrowly defined
ordinarily applicable
so do we have an existing situation that
works and is functional
and and would would that be
substantially enhanced by some of these
proposed changes uh uh at the expense of
workability uh in which case I think
that it would not be wise to proceed and
so I would ask you to to opine on uh
whether we whether we do do have such a
functional situation at the moment or
whether it's
sufficiently dysfunctional that we need
to change it in the matter proposed in
this bill
thank you I think gel Carr and the
administrative procedures Act is
functional as it is there's always room
for improvement 541a gets amended if not
every year then every two or three years
to try to improve things it's gotten
more complex over the years but
it used to be more cut and dry if you
had an issue then there was going to be
an objection the agency would have to go
back committee the legislature has
created options so it's become a little
more complex
um
you did mention the I mean I
to more directly answer your question I
think legislative oversight is a good
thing and the more involvement there are
there is by the entire legislature the
better
as representative McGuire said you you
know you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make them drink if the
legislators individual legislators don't
want to get involved then that's their
choice
you did mention Finance Financial
considerations and I do know that this
bill does not have a fiscal note and I
think they would be very significant uh
Financial impacts created
okay thank you oh
I think that one thing that if anyone in
the legislature is concerned about the
rules should do first is clean up the
rulemaking authority so that it only
covers what they want the rules to do as
opposed to just saying implement this
chapter or whatever we've tried to do
that on various occasions but it still
an agency is given broad Authority
and
and then some people don't like that
idea but if you don't if you do give
them broad Authority it's very hard to
it's very difficult to find that find
that fine line between
giving them too much Authority and
giving them enough of authority to do
what they need to do
else representative lacas just a thought
on that one I mean it might be if there
was some process to call out or identify
easily any bill that's granting
rulemaking Authority
um
and maybe have some process to
review it gel car or somebody and at
least point out to the policy committee
that maybe they might want to tighten it
up
as a matter of fact according to house
rules the vice chair of the committee is
supposed to review rulemaking Authority
and make sure it is not excessive
that is uh
as a vice chair of my acquaintance
was surprised when he discovered that
was his his duty and said nobody ever
told us about this so that is a
requirement in house rules that is not
always followed as thoroughly as I would
like
but yeah uh for members not familiar
with the rule making process I would
point out that most of the authority
when it when a rule comes before gel car
most of the authority has been granted
uh years past and the agencies coming
forward to just simply read off the
rules or do a tweak with the read option
with Amendment
obviously each year you do Pass New
bills and there is new rulemaking
Authority but most of the things before
okay well we'll we'll keep that in mind
because I I know that um
in 11.
I and a number of rule of agencies spent
the summer converting broad rulemaking
Authority into specific rule-making
Authority
and that was a major exercise we didn't
catch all of the spots
but we did for example put the Medicaid
Program into specific rulemaking
Authority rather than the commissioner's
broad rulemaking Authority which I
thought was a worthwhile effort
um but something like that needs to be
done on a regular basis the same way we
look at the Committees and commissions
we have you know you've created and
you've got to look at it every
some number of years and say is this
still a good idea
well this was one of the things that I
well recall when you joined the
legislature a few years after I come
came on board uh that and it came on on
the gel car that you know there was a
lot of very broad rule-making Authority
granted to Commissioners uh basically
said Commissioners shall write rules to
implement this statute well
that's like sending the the Army off and
go out there and do something win this
war and uh
a lot of very significant structures
were built on that kind of authority but
the agencies actually were not that
enthusiastic about it because uh it made
them completely responsible for every
aspect of it that was on that kind of a
basis and they like much more narrowly
tailored rule-making Authority that says
shall do this about that
so yes I know I remember
one rule writer bitterly and I'm
averting about the uh the sludge rules
yes it representative go forth and do
well
um just on that process you're involved
in in tightening up the rules was that
just a sub uh committee or subcommittee
to Edina standing committee that did it
there was some process set up to do that
or what problem to Bill
they a enthusiastic member of the
legislature put in a Bill to delete
a large number of
broad rulemaking Authority statutes and
it was retained in committee and we
worked out specific requirements for
those sections
it was a significant effort imagine
also have issues
okay well
all right we I will relate to the
sponsor that uh
we're going to it
we've got to find out what her real goal
is in putting this in other than to get
the legislator legislature involved
which I am
curious how she's going to manage that
because I don't believe passing a law
will do it
all right anyone else
that case thank you all for coming and
we will this will probably meet on this
again in
um September
I don't expect to need to have
um some of these same points brought up
again but we'll see